prove it
if you've got a great idea for a new
product or service you think will change
the world you have to prove it you've
got to prove that what you're saying is
right that what your idea is is going to
work and if that happens you're going to
get
customers you're going to get media
attention you get investors you're going
to get potential
acquisition targets from companies
they're going to want to be a part of
you because it works but if all you have
is a theory or an idea
it's not going to take off you need to
prove it
i got a question from one of my youtube
viewers i love you guys
uh srinivas i hope i pronounced that
properly
saying evan thanks for all your videos i
got an idea what you can bring the email
concept to the next level and i can
contribute in many ways
i want to sell this thing to google
hotmail yahoo i don't know how to
approach some things in advance
you gotta prove it you gotta prove that
this thing works the best thing you can
do is go out build some kind of
application that can sit on top of
gmail or yahoo or hotmail
that proves that your concept of email
works
there's a couple that i've used i forget
the name of it now a boomerang is one
that i've used so boomerang
is a tool that lets you send email later
so i could create an email and i don't
want it to send right now but i want it
to send next week in two hours next
month i can send it to myself i can send
it to
whoever i'm emailing and it's an add-on
tool that you can build into gmail i
don't know if they've done it for the
outlook hotmail you need to start
building momentum whatever your idea is
for email is great but you need to start
building something that shows that it
works and you can use the existing
infrastructure and build on top of those
companies email clients to start
building traction you need to show
people want to use this that they're
getting real results from it that people
would hopefully be willing to pay for a
premium package of this
when you do that you start getting
interest in the media you start getting
into some investors and companies like
google yahoo hotmail whoever will be
interested in potentially buying you
here's the thing that happens okay when
a company wants to acquire a business
usually what they'll do is they'll look
at if it's a technology company they
look at their their cto they look at
their chief technology officer and
they'll say how long will it take to do
this this is what i had to get into when
i sold my software company okay the
the company that bought us basically
looked at their own department and said
how long will it take us to do what
they've done to do what my company did
both in terms of creating the technology
and
getting the customer acquisition and the
time to market
how long would it take us to replicate
it
it may take six months it may take them
a year may take two years then they put
a value on that
okay it's gonna take us
you know six months and
x amount of dollars so that to us is
going to cost this amount of money this
is how much we can afford to go and
acquire the company for
that's the decision
so for you to get your lead for you to
get interest you have to get some good
technology that works and you've got to
get people using it you got to get some
momentum with it and quite often it's
going to be the company who's not number
one this is the biggest mistake that
i've ever made in my business
ever in my business career this was my
single biggest mistake
was i targeted the wrong company
i knew that i wanted to get my company
sold there was a lot of of acquisitions
happening in my industry and i knew it
was time to sell it
and i went after the number one company
in new zealand went after the top player
so for you would be going after gmail
right of the three gmail is the biggest
it's going after google
the number one guy rarely is interested
in acquiring to grow
because they're already at the top
the company that ended up being the
biggest player in my space that i
completely ignored was the number four
player they raised a huge fund they
raised 800 million dollars to go out and
start buying companies and they talked
to us they talked to me about my company
and i was one of two finalists and they
ended up buying my biggest competitor
for 40 million dollars
and that could have been me
if i was more prepared
i was geared towards a different company
so if you want to get bought out
think about who's trying to challenge
gmail who's trying to challenge hotmail
yahoo who wants to leapfrog over them
and take your technology and take your
customers to help them gain an edge
those are the guys who are going to pay
big money for you but you've got to
prove it first
nobody's going to buy you out
of just an idea
and for those of you watching you have a
technology concept you have any idea to
grow a business
people will not pay attention unless
you've got some traction and you prove
it when i was in the vc world i got
business plans thrown at me tons of
business plans people wanted funding
people wanted us to help them build a
business and get acquired if all you had
was an idea
your idea was going to throw in the
garbage can you had to have momentum and
traction you needed to have some
customers you didn't have to be making a
lot of money but prove to me that
somebody's willing to buy what you have
one person even if one person bought
what you had you'd be ahead of 90 of the
companies that we saw
get some momentum get some traction
prove that your ideas work and even on a
small scale
and then you become an interesting
acquisition target investment target
customer target media target and so on
you got to prove it
believe
for those of you watching you like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
it always makes me want to do more for
you and leave a comment below let me
know what you think you liked the video
you didn't leave it below you got a
question for your company i'll make your
video response leave it in the comments
below thank you so much and i'll see you
soon
you